[Music]
haha happy Monday welcome to every damn
day we're gonna talk about cardi B and
Nicki Minaj getting in a fight we're
gonna talk about the new sad Easter egg
and the ps4 spider-man game but first
watch this video of a brave dog and a
bouncy old bear so do we is there any
chance this is a wild grizzly or
domesticated babe I think what is that
the bravest dog of all time I think it's
a brave dog regardless but also let it
bears on like a city street it's no way
it's just a wild I know they get into
stuff real much would be the guy filming
just letting his dog maybe get torn up
by this bear I think that they just like
trimmed it so that you see the dog like
just get viciously mauled and the guy
dies too unlikely animal friends yeah of
course
I'd like to own a record they're very
smart
Natacha famously has raccoon energy oh
yeah yeah I want to have one there's
photos of him in the house you can't
have a rock yes yeah no you can't be a
raccoon
all right YouTube get Natasha racoon
well those two animals did not fight in
that video but two humans who did get in
a fight over the weekend that's a segue
Nicki Minaj and cardi B throw up that
headline Julianne
so this was at the Harper's Bazaar icons
party Nicki Minaj is not gonna press
charges after cardi B attempted to
attack her evidently she kind of rushed
her but because Nicki Minaj of course
has like 10 bodyguards she couldn't get
close so all she was able to do is throw
a shoe but then check out this photo for
some reason Kobe is the one leaving the
party with a well it looks like she got
hit that's huge that's a big well Wow
unexplained well it was my choice to
have this she's on and then her take on
it all next slide Jillian so this is
from her Instagram I'll let you read the
whole thing you can check it out but
basically what she's saying is that you
know you can talk trash but as soon as
you talk about me being a mother then
I'm gonna come at you like cardi B is
made out to be the crazy lady but
literally Nicki Minaj is probably the
crazy lady like she's the quiet crazy
throws a shoe is crazy what you guys
think and you don't just wake up you
never woken up like you know some today
the damn throwing shoes like you got to
get pushed to the point some people like
that and also you can't be like I'm such
a good mother and then throw your shoe I
mean I don't know if I can agree with
that so much I'm gonna punch Travis
Scott in the face like I'm gonna beat
everyone up and then cardi B just did it
yes you she face to face it was like
yeah where's all that now do rappers
have to argue to stay relevant oh this
is nothing this is the difference I
think cardi B really isn't like really
groomed industry wise she's just like a
personal
she got famous for doing this good stuff
no not really she got famous from
talking very honestly on an Instagram
about being separate and all that other
stuff Nicki Minaj on the other hand
became she's very industry driven and
she creates controversy around the album
she didn't have any contract - two
months ago now all said her album is out
and of course as we heard it's not doing
too great
okay Scott so here T the party and all
this I'm definitely team Carney I'm not
seeing anybody here this is like but I'm
right about this I'm team shoot great
that shoe who has gotten shoes thrown at
them the person who got a shoe sort of
created that anger like I created enough
anger inside that person throw what you
[Laughter]
that she was probably a thousand dollars
so to throw it at someone Nicki Minaj
you take your shoe up you throw it at
somebody that is your fault you did that
yeah you threw the shoe but from this
dog I just walk away yeah also Ryan and
Chris did you hear a few seconds ago
when I said cardi B as we all now has
bloody shoes no I really like that song
and with that transition to our next
topic
so sometimes things get sad out there on
the Internet
the new spider-man video game just came
out and there's an Easter egg in it
which is fun but it's actually a sad
Easter egg insomniac just released the
game for ps4 show that next slide a
Twitter user top notch 12:10 back in May
tweeted hey could you please help me
propose to my girlfriend I want to do it
in a big grand romantic gesture
insomniac replied yeah just wait until
September it came out show the
next slide join this is in the game you
can go find this Maddy will you marry me
nice cool thing and then it turns out a
couple weeks before the game came out
they split up to my question she left
him for his brother yes I should have
said Maddie will you marry me and not
leave me for my brother in the game from
the brother oh this is not a great way
to propose unless she's like so into
video games that she's gonna organically
find this but like if I did this I'd be
like calling my girlfriend from the
other room and you'd be like no look
look at the no no I'm spider-man just no
look at the yeah I know it's your name
it's no I did that no but the game the
developers did it she is very much into
games that's why I she left for the
brother because they all just usually
sit pray in one room and play the game
so she only left because he's okay they
sit in the room and it's three of them
may have played a little game and she
sees that and I knew she was the only
other person she knows is her brother so
she leave you for him for five years
playing the game together and then five
years you're just pulling stuff no I
don't know what Christmas screenplay is
all about
[Laughter]
[Music]
James and his brother like play sports I
was gonna say do you think the big grand
romantic gestures like this are ever a
good idea that's a big grand romantic
gesture I mean this is this game baby
dollars that's pretty big this dollar is
$80 I mean to develop it probably cause
a good he didn't pay for anything sent a
tweet he's the last big romantic gesture
I did like a big one was I me I spent
like a week making a mash-up of a
Michael Jackson song and a Jesse
McCartney song and I just mailed it in
this in a CD form to someone I was
seeing and she wrote back like I think
we should maybe not talk for a little
bit the master was good briefly guy was
seeing who was an animator and he made
me an animation of me like it was like a
funny story I told and it was really
good and I dated him for like a week
longer because it seems like the moments
passed it Hannah do you have a shout out
for us yes I do this year well our first
sketch drops on Friday about finding the
bad boy of the show Hannah why don't you
start us off
this is so stupid why are we even doing
this I'm clearly the baddest danger
taste then I show up whenever I want
I wear a leather jacket I put four loko
in all of the couch cushions and I've
been replacing Ryan's coffee with dip
spit for weeks the viewers don't believe
you're a bad boy material why cuz I'm a
woman yes our research shows that our
audience hates women and want to make
Comedy Central great again that means
bad boys and saying the phrase I'm Rick
James bitch 12 FW
said I'd say Hannah she basically has
the highest tea count over anyone else
on this show all right check out every
day I'm sketch show where do you do
something different right now hello and
welcome to my show and tell this is the
segment where I usually share some of
the really cool projects that I'm
working on but I'm going to do something
a little different this time and so this
past weekend I went upstate to a
lakeside cabin with my friends and we
just caught up and barbecued and went
swimming and it was like it was really
great and so I know this is lame but I'm
just gonna show some vacation footage
from the trip you could just pull that
up
[Music]
so what are some vacations you've guys
have gone on recently
y'all broke up with afterwards where
they already own the bubble do you think
that was the last there was a but you do
think of the hammer is coming bro I'm
gonna avoid her for another week you're
gonna be like that's a hell man with
that will you own the bubble
did you know you own the boat with this
person yeah we are on the bubble is the
bubble
[Laughter]
[Music]